the minute you act like you're doing
somebody a favor i personally think
you're dead in the water
how is pitching in hollywood different
from pitching in silicon valley
that's a really good question
and
my view is
i wouldn't structure it as how are they
different i'd see them as two points on
a continuum
because there's a lot of overlap in any
good kind of pitch
but
clearly you're talking about one very
specific type of product
in hollywood versus
you know an infinite
set of things that you can pitch
but the basic ideas are always going to
be the same
right that
there are a number of factors
again i
i keep wanting to move us into
persuasion because i love talking about
persuasion the psychology of persuasion
is an incredible area
and
we know a lot now about how people make
decisions that we didn't know a while
ago
and
one one of the interesting things for
example
um
have you
heard of a book called thinking fast and
slow daniel kahneman
i haven't read it but i've seen it
please for your sake read it
it's the best book i've read in decades
the man is so smart it will scare you
but one of the major theses of the book
is that
when we solve problems
there are two ways we can go
we can think about it very very deeply
or we can use our intuition
and a good part of the research that
he's done
says if you ask people how they process
they say deeply
if you watch the solutions they come up
with they're almost always
intuitive
now
in intuition sounds like a flighty kind
of idea but intuition is
based on everything you know
everything you believe
all of your history so it's a vast
storehouse of information
so you're not always starting from
scratch
the interesting thing about this
is
if you're pitching
anything
screenplay a new detergent doesn't
matter
you start out with the idea that you'd
like to keep people processing the
information you're telling them at the
intuitive level
because if it's in the intuitive level
then everything is fine
everything goes and fits with your
background and everything you believe
the minute you make somebody go into
deep hard thought
one you don't like it
because
it's hard to do you know anybody who
enjoys doing math problems when they
don't have to you know
immediately sour mood
and it immediately makes you skeptical
because it doesn't fit your background
it doesn't fit who you are and the way
you think about things
so if you're forced to go out of that
comfort zone and work really hard
you you become
much more difficult to persuade
so one of the things that we talk about
if you're pitching
hollywood or anywhere else got to do a
tremendous amount of research before you
go in on the people that you're pitching
to
and
again you want to know what are the
things they've done
particularly what are the things they've
done that they're proud of and feel good
about
and we had a story in there
a friend of ours larry bresner
um produced a movie called the burbs
he
hated the movie because the studio made
him change the ending
and if you went in and pitched a project
to him saying
i love your work particularly i love the
verbs you're out of the office
so you need to to be thinking about
what's somebody's sweet spot how can i
start out going in that area
do your homework
i don't think enough people
do their homework in any area because
they think what they've got is so
original and so amazing
they don't
study what's come before
and what people like and don't like
so i think the larry story is a great
example and we've got other ones like
that from business people
there's one great story of um
i believe it was your friend the vice
president
at boeing
and this guy walked in i may have this
wrong because it's a long book it's a
great book it's very engaging
but um i'm just saying i'm just having a
conversation about it i'm not pushing it
but
i believe it it was lexus or it was
toyota which is lexus jim press right
and this kid came in the room in bermuda
shorts and
flip-flops
and i hope i'm not conflating two
stories but it doesn't matter hawaiian
shirt and a hawaiian shirt and he had a
briefcase on his lap and he kept telling
them all the things he was going to do
to save them money and he doesn't
realize that they're spending
billions of dollars trying to get better
fuel efficiency
he never takes anything out of the
briefcase he acts like he's doing them a
favor
of course they didn't do business with
him
the minute you act like you're doing
somebody a favor i personally think
you're dead in the water
you know to amplify that point and
jeffrey was talking about it before
whenever you pitch
you're pitching two things
your project yourself
and
what you're hoping for is that they're
saying
i may not go for this idea but i could
see myself in business with this person
right so i would call on them you know i
got the rights to this novel
need somebody to write it i'm going to
give this guy a shot
that's a nice thing if you're doing a
good job
so again
somebody gives you notes you start
quarreling with them
oh you never want to see that person
again
right so you're always thinking of
how can you be genial
how can you be nice how can you
how can you avoid looking arrogant
and we
we we looking arrogant
i'm not doing my job you know it's
interesting because that you bring this
up you might want to cut this out but
it's interesting because i think the
business is changing but all businesses
are changing and that is they don't want
to do
business with arrogant entitled people
um
uh abrams came to the university a year
or two ago jj and you know he's show
business his dad was a his second
generation his dad was a big tv movie
producer in the 90s
and he said to the students
you come out of school and come to work
for me major producer jj right
and the day you show arrogance or
entitlement like where's my corner
office with the view and my parking
space you're fired
we're not putting up with that anymore
and i think the greatest example of that
is
i won't mention his name but he's done i
mean he's very wealthy
but there was no sexual allegations or
anything like that he just treated
people so badly through
chairs at them
he's done
i think that signals a really good
change in industry and there's just too
much work
and too many and just why can't you be
nice i mean that's the thing is you
don't have to be a jerk
we had a
a fellow we were talking to
you know when somebody comes in and says
i'm a graduate of the yale drama school
i was top of my class i got
you immediately hate that person right
so this guy had gone to the ucla i mean
the usc film school yeah and you know
it's always rated the number one film
school in the country and instead of
saying i'm a usc film school graduate he
said you know what they taught me in the
usc film school program
whenever you leave the set
it should be exactly the way you found
it
right and so he used self-effacing humor
to make fun of this is all i learned
but i did sneak in the fact that i went
to usc but i didn't do it like this
right and then the the other point is
you are
when you do what peter so
confusingly dramatized
um
with that thing um you're
you're
not you're not very smart because if
they invite you in they know where you
went to school they're not taking you're
not nobody comes off the street you know
this better than we do you've
interviewed tons and tons and tons of
people nobody takes an interview with
someone that they don't know something
about that would be crazy
and it's never been that way but one one
final note on this and then maybe we'll
move on to another question but have we
gotten though a little too soft in terms
of
well this person said this and i just
feel that it's inappropriate and now oh
yes we have we almost can't say anything
yes i think we're going through that
phase i've i see it at or i see it
and i hope that the pendulum will swing
back to normal because it gets a little
crazy for example since we're talking
about show business today as well as
business
if you're going to write it's one thing
at a school or a university if you're in
a writer's room
and people are not talking about
disliking a certain group of people
you know personally that's one thing but
if in the script
it pushes your buttons and you can't or
as the nude phrases it triggers you
um
i really have to learn to do this better
yeah i like it when you do that
because that is the new phrase it
triggers you
and you can't deal with it and you say
i'm sorry to the producer i have to
leave the room
because the material is triggering me i
wish you luck in your career in any
career in silicon valley we're not
sitting around saying oh you know i
don't like this or that group of people
we're talking about it within the work
and i think that's where it might be
getting too sensitive
that
you've got to learn to deal with all
subjects whether you're and i think
that's what you're asking right i mean
it's one if you're if you're being
insulting and nasty to people
and it has nothing to do with what
you're working on that's a whole other
story but i do think that we're going
through an over correction that's just
my opinion but
you seem to feel that way and you well i
mean i'm i'm generation x but i do see
that it feels like maybe there's too
much coddling going on i don't have
children so i can't really speak from
the viewpoint of a parent but it does
seem like maybe we're getting a little
bit too
precious
and
i think that i mean again i'm not a
psychologist but um i have a very close
you work with one i work with one
another once again i have a daughter who
has her msw now since i've seen you so
so um and she's in that phase fairly new
msw who so she is analyzing oh
everything that we say you know what you
really mean is
you know
but peter told me not to worry that he
did that that it's a part of the
it's a writer passage yeah okay right
right it's an annoying rite of passage
i'll tell you that for other people but
um no i i do i agree with you i i think
that
but i do think that it the pendulum is
going to have to swing back because
it's crazy now it's just nuts
well it's actually going down political
lines which is